[Music]
i think it's catastrophic
we don't know exactly uh how
bad it is but the numbers that we're
seeing are
uh alarming uh the rate of positivity
that is the testing the positivity that
we've seen in the
limited testing that exists um indicate
that these numbers are
uh just through the roof so we're seeing
a very
steep spike from all the indications
that we can
can have but again it's limited it's
limited by just
lack of access to some of the vital
information but also
because of misinformation that we're
likely to get from the
military hunter
they're not reliable um i think it's
probably um
any any official figures we get from the
government i think we can just assume
that the numbers are actually
uh significantly uh higher uh than what
we're we're hearing we don't know quite
how high we're we're
um looking at as much information as
possible but again we know
that this the the cases are spiking the
deaths are spiking and we know that
particularly vulnerable populations are
in extreme danger right now
[Music]
you know we have um thousands of
political prisoners for example
some with underlying conditions that are
in horrific conditions
and we have people crowded uh into rooms
hundreds
uh in some cases without access to
hygiene
without any protective any masks or
anything that would protect them
and no treatment whatsoever with people
showing clear signs
of infection um so under those
conditions cobot is just going to run
rampant
and we have thousands of political
prisoners in those prisons including
opposition leaders political leaders and
we know that
uh their their life is in danger
you know the public uh call all the
doctors as
heroes heroes due to our actions in the
open pandemic last year
but we have become criminals overnight
by the military doctors and nurses and
other health care professionals
uh are wanted uh there's hundreds of
arrest warrants outstanding right now
for them they're being harassed and
they're being arrested as we speak i
mean it is just
absolutely incredible to me and i think
to any sane person
to think that um here's a regime
facing this extraordinary catastrophe
uh and spending its time uh harassing
and arresting
uh doctors and nurses and other
healthcare professionals i mean the fact
is
you can't fight covet 19 and
be attacking doctors and nurses and
health care professionals at the same
time
any reasonable person would understand
that but to give you a sense
of what we're dealing with here uh the
the junta is spending
uh precious time and energy uh harassing
and arresting these physicians
[Music]
i think that there's there's been just
too much
inaction the people of myanmar don't
don't need more statements and they
don't
need more declarations they need action
they need help
and it's not forthcoming and i think
it's important for the international
community to look deep within itself
to look at the options that exist right
now that are not being exercised
and seize them because really we don't
have much time we're almost six months
into this crew
hundreds and hundreds of people have
been killed untold numbers are being
tortured
um people continue to be arrested
attacks continue
all over the country and on top of that
we have covert 19 and this delta variant
so this is a catastrophe on top of a
catastrophe
[Music]
so many many healthcare professionals
around the world are exercising great
courage and confronting this
this disease that obviously particularly
with the delta variant is so contagious
but in myanmar they're not only
confronting covet they're confronting
a military regime that's attacking them
so it is unique and we
know the steps that can be taken to
reduce
the risk of covet but we also know what
can be done to try and reduce
the risk of attack by the military
regime and that's called pressure
and what we need in myanmar is not just
emergency medical assistance
but we need emergency international
engagement
pressuring the military junta to stop
its reign of
terror on the people of myanmar
[Music]
you